these ships show Port calls at Ukraine's
Black Sea ports and the days before
Russia invaded the country here's how
that compares to the days after the
fighting broke out six months after the
war started under the Black Sea grain
initiative and then again this summer
after the Black Sea grain deal fell
apart they show how moscow's economic
war against Ukraine is playing out in
the Black Sea causing key Ukrainian
exports to plunge something Russia has
benefited from as its exports are
reaching record highs so how has Russia
sought to control shipping to and from
Ukraine and what are kieving its allies
trying to do to counter that blockade
before the war Ukraine's black seaports
exported 95 of the country's wheat corn
and sunflower oil Ukraine's agricultural
products account for 41 percent of the
country's total exports meaning they are
major drivers of Ukraine's economy
wanting to choke Ukraine off financially
Russia has taken aim at these ports
since the invasion began it's done this
in a number of different ways it's tried
to capture some strategic port cities
and it's bombarded others with missiles
it's also destroyed infrastructure used
to export grain and moved warships into
shipping corridors now there has been a
caveat last July in Turkey Moscow under
diplomatic pressure agreed to a U.N
broker deal known as the Black Sea grain
initiative that paved the way for
Ukrainian food products and only food
products to flow from these three ports
you can see that Port calls picked up
but they never fully recovered to those
pre-war levels and Russia was accused of
slowing down shipping by holding up
inspections then this summer shipping
came to a standstill once again after
Russia withdrew from that Black Sea
grain deal and threatened all commercial
ships heading toward Ukraine
so how are Kiev and its allies racing to
keep Ukraine's economy and its critical
food products plugged into the rest of
the world early in the war the European
Union established these solidarity Lanes
to move products in and out of the
country via Road rail and inland
waterways over much of the past year
those Overland routes handled about 24
percent of Ukraine's grain exports while
the black seaports handled 50 percent
ports over here on the Danube River
handle the remaining 26 percent now
following the collapse of that grain
deal the U.S is leading an effort to
increase capacity here where grain is
shipped down the Danube River and
Through Romania's ports on the Black Sea
even though this route is slower and
more expensive than using Ukraine's
black seaports it's considered to be
safer since it lies under the NATO
umbrella ships would travel through the
waters of Romania Bulgaria and turkey
those countries are part of NATO whose
31 members consider an attack on one to
be an attack on all now the UN and
turkey are still trying to get Russia
back into that green deal but that might
not happen so Ukraine is also working to
open a shipping Corridor in the Black
Sea that would allow ships to hug
Ukraine's Coast before Sailing by those
NATO countries that could help Ukrainian
Farmers earn more money but Ukraine's
ability to resume exports this way
depends on whether ships can get
insurance and whether captains are
willing to take the risk because Russia
isn't guaranteeing them safe Passage
the true test for Ukraine and its allies
will come in September and October when
the country's massive harvests are
brought in but some Ukrainian Farmers
have already given up on planting their
crops since the market and supply chain
are broken and there are no signs of the
War ending anytime soon now as Russia
threatens these new routes the U.S says
it's considering all possible options
including military solutions to protect
the ships heading to these ports and
analysts say the threat of a broader War
spilling into the Black Sea is higher
than at any point since the conflict
began